OK, good morning,
everybody. Thank you for joining us
today. So just uh
I wanna start off with this just sort of a quick bit of
interactivity, get a sense of who's in in the
room. How many of you are actively
developing in a in a multi-cloud environment at this
point? Good, good. And
those of you who, OK, keep your hands up for a second, those of you who
are actively in a multi-cloud environment, how
many of you just love all the fun new
stuff and tools and things you have to deal with?
Yeah, very few,
right? Good. Well, that's awesome.
Uh, I'm Clark Ritchie. I'm a principal
technologist here at AWS, and
I'm joined by Eric Weber, who's a senior, uh,
solutions architect at AWS.
And this is exactly the problem
that we're here to help you with today is all
that giant amount of of of
tools and stress you have to deal with in
a multi-cloud scenario.
So we'll talk today a little bit about
some of uh you know the goal overall for the session
uh and the challenges that.
You're all keenly aware of in multi-cloud,
uh, and then we'll get into the meat of it. Eric's gonna
talk to you about centralized node management,
observability,
uh, and we're gonna give you some real customer
stories
on how customers are actually doing this in the real
world and of course some resources
on where to go for next steps.
And really again, this is about all of you, so all
of you who quickly put your hands down
when I asked if this was really fun to have to deal with
all the complexity and the new things
you have to learn and the different tool sets.
This is to help you
make your jobs and your life
easier.
We're actually gonna give you.
Tools and techniques that are actionable
and practical
right now. And
we're gonna give you examples of that after so Eric's gonna give you
real live demos showing you how it can be done
very simply, and we'll give you some customer stories
that show how customers have achieved actual
return on investment and gotten time back
from doing exactly these things.
So in just a level set,
let's define multi-cloud. If I'm
sure if I'd ask all of you, we'd get 100
or so different answers and that's totally fine.
Uh, for the purposes of the talk at
AWS we define being
multi-cloud as running.
One or more of your
applications in different workloads. So maybe
run one in AWS, some one somewhere else.
That's what we define as multi-cloud. If you
just are using one primary cloud provider and
say you're using a SAS service like
Office 365,
that's great,
no problem there,
but that's not what we're really talking about when
we talk about multi-cloud here at AWS.
And so of course as we just talked about, you know, we're all
racing into multi-cloud,
uh, many of us very intentionally
to
drive business outcomes that we're looking
to achieve.
And sometimes kind of multi cloud gets thrust
upon us, right? We have mergers and acquisitions
and next thing you know
you're in more clouds than you ever thought possible
and this of course requires new skill
sets, new training,
new tools, new run books, new
processes,
and we know that it can be
a lot.
So today we're gonna hope to give you some techniques
and some tips
to help you manage and deal with that
and make your life simple. So with that I'm gonna
turn it over to Eric.
Awesome, thank you.
So kind of recapping what was being mentioned,
you know, working on different tools
depending on the environment that we're referring to.
So like we mentioned at the beginning, we're going to
talk first about, you know, centralized node management,
uh, so moving towards getting an understanding
of where our resources are and how we can operate
on them after they're provisioned.
So some of the challenges that we hear in this, you
know, multi-cloud space for node management is, of
course, just getting an understanding of what is your
current inventory. Where are you running servers
and VMs? Are they EC2 on AWS?
You know, are they VMs over in Azure or GCP?
Are they even in an on-prem environment or even
at the edge?
So getting, uh, you know, that foundational
piece of where our resources are running
are critical.
Once we have that established, then we need
to start operating them,
so we'll talk about observability in a moment, but
some of the other challenges when you are operating these
long standing resources or even
short term,
you may also have to deal with patch compliance,
especially when we're talking about regulatory
requirements or even just internal security
requirements that you may need to adhere to. Do
we use ideally a centralized
tool to have our patch scans
in place so we know exactly where those
resources are noncompliant,
how long they've been noncompliant, what is the
upcoming patch schedule or frequency
for when that should be remediated
and to help alleviate some of those concerns you may have.
Another common challenge is direct
RDP or SSH from the
internet. We want to improve our overall
security footprint. We want to do away with
direct connections to these resources.
Remove Port 22 or 3389
from these inbound security group rules. Insistences
Andrew, which we'll talk about, uh, helps you accomplish
that. And then the last
thing is talking about, you know, improving our
overall automations, you know,
rather than performing every single, every single
thing manually, you know, having that direct
connection, you know, going and logging into a node,
running commands.
Let's talk about how we can actually perform this at
scale to help speed up our DevOps
processes. So
what can we use to do that? Well, AWS Systemsander
is going to be the service, you know, that we can use to manage
resources wherever they are.
You know, it's based off of the Systemsandra agent
or SSM agent, as you'll hear it.
Uh, let's go back.
I think it might have an automatic timer, so,
uh, for the Systemsander agent,
we can install it on AWS Resources,
on-prem, at the edge, or even
other cloud providers. We'll keep this here for a
second. And, uh, when we're
talking about AWS, a wide variety of our AMIs
are even going to have it pre-baked in.
And once you have that agent in place,
uh, you can then go ahead and perform all these
node management related tasks or even patching
as well as gathering that inventory.
All right, so now we're ready to go to the slide.
So let's kind of go through each of those four challenges
that I highlighted at the beginning, and we can talk
about how we can, you know, kind of get started
as well as then automate, uh, some of these tasks,
and then we'll even jump into the console afterwards.
So just building out that foundation of
a centralized inventory,
knowing what we need to uh operate
and where those resources reside.
So like I was just saying, it starts with the Systemsander
agent. Now on the left-hand side, we have
our other cloud provider,
on-prem environment,
wherever this uh server or VM resides,
and we, it starts with installing the System Xander
agent.
And as part of that process, you create
what we call a hybrid activation code. Think
of it very similar to an IM access key and
secret key, and we're passing it as part of our installation
to determine which account we want to register
it with, as well as which region, and then
also uh what IM role,
you know, to grant permissions for that agent.
So if you have a connection, you know, between these two
different environments, you can privately connect rather
than going over the public internet,
you know, establish a connection to the Systems Manager
VPC endpoint,
and this will begin that registration process.
So behind each of these SSM agents and
these hybrid activation codes is uh
an IM role that can be used by
the SSM agent, as well as your other
applications and resources that are on that same VM.
So, It'll generate
temporary STS tokens,
so these are going to be ephemeral. These will be constantly
rotated and handled by the SSM agent,
and they're made available to the operating system.
So if you do have other applications that need to
access AWS resources, you know, maybe you have
a web app that needs to access an S3 bucket
or maybe Dynamo DB or RDS,
you can grant that same role permissions and
allow those applications to use the same
temporary credentials that SSM agent
is vending out
uh to go ahead and access AWS resources. You don't,
you can move away
from having, you know, uh, long standing
hardcoded keys.
So, you know, that was kind of the, the manual
process, manually installing SSM age and, creating
that code. Let's talk about how we can automate
this a little bit more.
So, it starts with, you know, the servers or VMs,
uh, we'll take a look at an example script when I flip
over into the console, but essentially, whenever
a new node is spun up, let's go ahead
and uh bake in some user data
or even just an initial startup script to
go ahead and query, uh, what is going
to be an API uh gateway
endpoint. So the query
API gateway
behind that it's backed by lambda.
Lambda is going to perform just a quick evaluation,
you know, has this process been requested yet?
If not, we'll go ahead and proceed
and query, uh, what we're, what we're
going to be using, which is Systems and parameter
store. If you're not familiar with the parameter Store, the
name is pretty straightforward. You can store,
uh, keys and values in parameter
Store, you know, and then access them for your resources.
Now, the reason that this is all kind of required
is that, you know, in order to get this hybrid activation
code, you know, you could also store it in
an uh an external if you have an on-premise, you know, key
vault location,
but if we're trying to access AWS resources like
Parameter Store, we need AWS credentials.
So that's why API gateway is going to be that
intermediary part to be able to serve that
request without having credentials in the first place.
So once lambda verifies that the code is
ready, it'll then deliver it back
to those servers or VMs, and then the node can
go ahead and register.
And this is exactly how Rackspace is actually
doing it. So, you know, on the left hand side
you can see GCP, you can see Azure, you can
see VMware,
you know, they are going to be running these bootstrapping,
uh, scripts that will then go ahead and query an
API gateway endpoint.
Behind that, you know, they have a little bit of
a difference there, but it's going to be, you know, leveraging
lambda to then return back that hybrid
activation code ultimately so that all
these VMs, you know, that are just spun up,
uh, can go ahead and register with Systems Manager.
And you know by doing this, Rackspace is able
to automate their tasks across 100,000
plus DMs on a routine basis.
This is helping reduce the amount of manual
effort that is required.
You know, when you have systems and your agent installed, you can
bootstrap those resources, keep them in a
maintained configuration state.
You can have all of that patching, the session management
that we talked about, as well as just general inventory
data and the ability to run scripts on
them as needed.
So let's go ahead and flip over into the
console now.
All right, and just to get started.
Uh, so I just wanted to start on the Systems Andrew
landing page.
Now this is something, uh, that we launched last year, it's called the
Systems Andrew Unified Console.
You know, it's a way from a delegated administrator account
that you can aggregate data about all these managed
nodes into a single location.
And if we just start on, you know, the initial
dashboard, and we can get some quick
information, and this node summary is going to
highlight how many of our
managed nodes are currently registered
with Systems Manager. If there are any unmanaged
EC2 instances, it'll also highlight
those and it'll give you some options to go ahead and remediate
that. In the middle we can then see
an actual breakdown,
you know, in this simple environment we're just running 11 EC2
and we have about 18 hybrid nodes.
Again, hybrid can mean on-prem, other cloud,
wherever it is that's outside of AWS really.
Following that, we just have some initial information
about what SSM agents are out there
and then diving, you know, into the last two is just going
to be focused around the operating systems, you know, just
give a quick breakdown, is it Windows or Linux,
and then what is the actual operating system running
on each of those.
So from this single
location, we can then go to explore
our nodes and we can see the accounts and regions
as well as the organization units, you know, have
this centralized piece of information
so that we can then start working with our nodes and operating
on them. Now,
if we were to, you know, if we have
a new VM that we want to spin
up, like I mentioned, we can include
uh that bootstrapping uh script
within our, you know, VM image,
or ideally, you know, you can also pre-install the
Systems Manager agent.
And just to kind of jump through this real quick, I'm
over into the Azure console now. I'm gonna go ahead and
spin up an Azure VM,
uh, and we'll, we'll take a look at,
uh, how it is able to
then just automatically register through that process that
we're looking at earlier.
So we're not going to be doing anything too special.
We're just going to go with a lot of the, the basics
here. Uh, so we're just gonna
launch a new Ubuntu node. Uh,
so this was then just going to leverage
a key that I already have.
And then just a few more changes.
All right, just specifying some of the networking
information. Now, in this environment, you know, there is that
connection between uh my Azure VM
or virtual network, as well as uh with database
VPCs.
Um, so it is communicating privately, it doesn't have
to go over the public internet.
Now, you know, this one is still assigning a public
IP but we're just gonna go ahead and remove that
entry point for 22.
Now, the last thing, this is what I was mentioning earlier,
you know, having, uh, that bootstrapping script.
You know, the, the real thing in here,
uh, is that API gateway endpoint.
So again, you know, we need that resource to be
able to get those uh activation codes, uh, which
will take a look at what the an example is,
uh, but we
need that resource to be able to access these,
you know, outside of uh AWS and
prior to actually having credentials itself.
All right. So we will go ahead and launch this, and this will probably
take, you know, 2 to 4 minutes to actually
go ahead and uh register the resource.
Um, so while we are waiting for that, I
just wanna make sure it hits
the deployment. There we go.
So let's take a look at that hybrid activation
code that I've been talking about.
So over in uh the activations
section of the console,
you know, this is where I have a few different codes that
have been created, uh, but just to kind of talk
about this a little bit more.
Again, this is a code that's required
for that resource to know which account and which region
it should register with.
If you're creating it from the CLI or
our SDKs, you can also add some tags that
are automatically added, so you can tag these
hybrid nodes just the same as EC2
instances.
And the real important part that I was
highlighting earlier is this IM role section.
Now in the next section we're gonna talk about observability.
So how do I get, uh, you know, observability
through the cloudwatch agent?
So how do I get credentials to that node? Well,
I can attach cloud watch permissions to the role
that is associated with this code, and then the cloudwatch
agent can go ahead and uh ingest
those credentials and, you know, be able to put
logs and metrics.
So if I just create this activation code,
uh, we then just see that we have this code
as well as an ID which we would then,
you know, normally include within a bootup,
or sorry, like our bootstrapping script.
But these codes, you know, they have an expiration
date of a maximum of 30 days.
So that's why, you know, having some of this automation
behind an API gateway with lambda, you know,
can help
speed up that process so you are not constantly
updating your existing scripts.
So if we go back to the explore nodes
section, let's see if it's uh registered now. Yeah,
so we now have 30
managed resources uh rather than 29.
If we jump back to Azure, let's just check
the IP address for this new one.
So it's 0.07.
So if we take a look at our
resources here.
Mm, so there's our
new
Azure VM4 resource that we
just spun up.
So now it's going to go ahead and perform a
few different evaluations, um, within Systems
Manager.
But, you know, now that we have it as a registered device,
we can go ahead and just start running, uh, our
different tools on it,
you know, so there's uh, a wide variety of
tools that are available out of the box, you know, that you can
use, uh, to grant access,
you know, to your day to day operators that may need
to interact with these resources.
Kind of the huge benefit here is that you know
we don't have to allow actual OS
level access, you know, they can run these commands
from the AWS console, from the AWS CLI, from
our APIs and SDKs,
and interact with it without having to, you
know, fully connect to the operating system itself.
You know, some of the other tools here, let's go ahead and take a
look at just some performance counters
and if we want to just get some on-demand
metrics, you know, get a quick view
at the CPU utilization, maybe disk input
output,
memory usage, or even network traffic, you know, just
getting a quick spot check on how
this node is doing after being spun up just
a few minutes ago.
Uh, let me actually just pull up one of our other,
uh, resources that I deployed earlier
as well.
So this one, if we actually check
its processes,
uh, so when I select,
you know, the processes tool, it's going to uh
establish a connection with SSM agent.
If you're not familiar or if you're not aware,
the SSM agent works on outbound 443
traffic.
So everything is done through, uh, you know, a reverse
connection to our systems and endpoints. And again,
if you have those VPC endpoints deployed, the
node doesn't even have to have access to the internet
at all, and you can still remotely connect to
it and perform these tasks.
So this is going to start up that session against this
hybrid resource and now we can, you
know, get a quick look at what are the live
processes that are running on this node.
Now, earlier just before the session, you know, I
just spun up a stress NG just to go ahead
and peg the server,
but for any of these processes, you know, I can then go
ahead and terminate it,
just go ahead and, you know, stop that
stress test, you know, this, this node can go back to,
you know, it's typical 1 or 2%
CPU utilization.
So this is a great way to be able to interact
with these resources without having to fully
remotely connect.
And uh just to kind of recap
again, if we go back to, you know, the node insights,
you know this is a great way that we can start establishing
that centralized inventory and having these
tools available to us.
All right, so let's go back.
And we'll skip through some of these, so.
So we just talked about, you know, establishing
that centralized inventory, you know, the next step that actually
we actually want to go into is how we can,
uh, you know, overcome some of these struggles with patch
compliance.
All right, so
let's flip back into the console one
more time. Well,
actually, not one more time, but
if we then go over to the patch manager section
of the console, we can get a very quick glimpse
of how we are doing at the moment.
Now, this is very similar to that, that first
page, you know, give us a quick glimpse of how many
resources are registered with Systems Sander versus
those that are unmanaged.
You know, it looks like in this case,
about 10 of those nodes are noncompliant
with patching.
You know, we can always figure out
uh how many nodes are actually missing updates,
how many failed to perform uh that install,
are they pending any reboots,
and then how long, you know, has that resource
either been noncompliant or just never reported
patch compliant state in the first place.
So that brand new VM that we just launched, you
know, it's being identified,
hey, you don't know what the current patch compliant state
is now in this environment, I think I have daily
scans configured at 2 in the morning.
So that won't be flipped for a few
more hours, but we can see all of our resources,
our other resources have relatively fresh
data. So there's been patch compliance
information generated within the last 7 days.
We can see all of the the iterations
or actions that have been taken, taken
against this resource,
uh, and if we just want to go ahead and.
You know, scan that new Ubuntu node,
um, we can just select that patch now,
and this will give a few different options, uh,
but we are just gonna go with some of the basics for
just performing a quick scan and we'll just choose
our node manually.
So we will
select
one of those Ubuntu resources
and if we just hit patch now,
you know, this is going to kick off a patch scan.
It'll probably take 30 seconds to 1 minute.
Uh, so while we wait for that, you know, let's just go
ahead and uh talk one more
time about.
What are some of those challenges?
Uh, so,
you know, we just took a, a very brief look at
capturing patch compliance data,
and you can always aggregate this information as well. Systemsander,
uh, has what we call a resource data sync
to ship this data to an S3 bucket,
and there you have a centralized, you know, data source
for what is your patch compliance state across
AWS, Azure,
uh, wherever that resource is
residing.
So moving on to our next challenge, let's
talk about,
you know, in case those tools or remote
operations are not sufficient, you know, maybe
in an incident or an on-call
situation, you may need to actually go ahead and remotely connect.
So how can we do that in a secure way
rather than
allowing that
inbound access.
So If
we go back to exploring our nodes here.
And there it is, uh, so that
is the,
the new VM that we just provisioned.
So. Like what I was mentioning
earlier, and we talked about like EC2
instances, um, we can just go ahead and
remotely connect to them,
uh, so we don't have to allow inbound 22
or 3389, we can use Systemsander as
that, you know, essentially a network tunnel, you know, to
be able to remotely connect and start up these interactive
sessions.
Now I am starting this from the Abase console, but you
can also start up these sessions from the AWS CLI
as well. Uh, so, however,
you know, your users are connecting today,
and you may be able to use Session Manager to
improve your overall security footprint from a networking
perspective,
as well as then making definitions of which
nodes someone can connect to,
as well as the operating system user that they're connected
with, you know, through standardized IM
policies and roles.
So now that I am connected, you know, I can just go ahead
and start running, you know, all of my,
uh, commands as needed.
Let's just say hello,
reinvent.
Now the other main thing of session Manager is
that these commands that I'm issuing, I
can also specify for those to be logged, you
know, I can ship it either to cloudWatch logs, I
can ship it to an S3 bucket,
and that makes it available so that, you know, after these sessions
are terminated,
I could always go back and review, you know, what commands
were issued during that given time.
So if we jump over into the cloudwatch
console now.
We can go through to the
log management section,
uh, and then in here,
we have our cloud watch log group called
Session Manager.
So here we have all of those different streams
uh that we've been establishing
these sessions,
and now,
uh, I wish I could view this a little bit.
That's a little bit better maybe, but,
uh, so in here we can see that who am I
command that I just issued, you know, the, the
date, uh, even if we go all the way to the
bottom, hello, reinvent,
you know, this is a great way to have that
information available if you need to go back and reflect what
actions were taken by that operator during
a given session.
You can then also build out uh alarms
around it as well, you know, if users are entering
specific commands, you can kick off alarms
against that.
Uh, and if we, let's
check back on our
patch process, so.
It, uh, it went ahead and
performed that patch scan against that resource.
So now if we reflect back over to patch
manager. And
if we go over to compliance reporting,
let's see how many of those are actually missing.
So we have a wide variety of resources
again both in EC2
instance here as well as that hybrid resource
that is noncompliant. We can jump in
further if we want to drill into what are the specific
updates that are being marked as missing,
you know, prepare any of our applications or
app owners
for their awareness.
Here are those updates that are going to be installed.
So kind of recapping, you know, those challenges
again, uh, so now we just talked about
creating that interactive session without having
to access, uh, over the Internet.
Again, we can have those VPC endpoints
deployed if you have a connection between,
you know, your other cloud and AWS VPC.
It can be fully private and the node doesn't even
need internet access at all.
Now that last challenge, you know, being able to
perform actions at scale, of course, you know,
logging in like I just did, running those commands,
that's not efficient as soon as we probably get above
5, 10 nodes.
So if we need to actually perform some actions at scale,
you know, that's where Systems Sandra, uh, uh,
can also assist.
So if we go back into the console,
uh, what I'm gonna show here is an automation
runbook. Um, so if you're not familiar with
automation or run command,
This is a way to orchestrate a series of
steps and you know whether you're performing
AWBS related API calls or
if you need to interact with the operating
system of that managed node,
you can perform a series of different tasks
as required and I think as far as
out of the box there are some
400 plus
database runbooks, so it's another great way
to establish a good delegation of
permissions to your users.
You know, if a user needs to go and restart an EC2,
let's not give them direct access to that EC2
call. Let's give them access to automation
because we know it will be performed in a well-defined
manner, an expected manner.
So if we go over to my favorites, I just have a, a simple
run book here,
you know, let's imagine that I need to run a generic
script that just is going to be passed in
against this fleet of resources, whether they're
AWS, on-prem, other cloud, wherever
they may be. I'm gonna go ahead and run a script
on uh against them.
If we were to just take a look at
the authoring experience uh for
automation, I can zoom in here a little bit and walk
through what steps are being performed.
So using the, the automation runbook,
you know, visual designer, you can kind of just drag
and drop, you know, if you need to add more steps
uh to any of, any of your runbooks.
Now just to kind of walk through this, we're gonna
start with just describing a list of all of my nodes
in this account region.
Once we have that list, we can then loop through
that. We're gonna make a quick
determination is that resource a
Windows node or is it a Linux node,
you know, in order to then run the appropriate script,
you know, if you want to also include some additional
verification or branching,
you know, then we would include that logic as
required. In my case, if I take a look at
some of these examples and then just uh open
up one of these rules real quick.
Uh, in here I'm just making two evaluation
checks. One is the resource of Linux
box, and then two is the node actually
online. You know, if it's not online, we can go ahead and skip
it. We don't need to wait for that process to
complete. Now
when that is complete,
or when it,
when the criteria is met by that branching
option, we're then just going to run a
simple, you know, shell script, just taking
a look at the sys log or you know, messages
are present on the box, and
if so, we want to go ahead and store that
information in Dynamo DB.
You know, just go ahead and specify
whether or not it's true or false if that
file is present.
So if we flip back and we go over to execute
automation, this is going to use that run
book, and I will actually
just show the Dynamo DB table as well, just to
verify that there's nothing in there at the moment.
So we have this managed node log compliance
table here.
If we explore, you know, the
items, it's currently empty.
So we go back to automation
in this case,
you know, everything is baked in as far as
defaults for the parameters, but we can make this very dynamic
as needed, uh, even in passing,
you know, uh, locations or remote
locations for that script, so you don't necessarily
have to have everything together. You can
still use, um,
you know, some CICD best practices.
Now this is going to start iterating through all of
those, you know, 30 nodes at this point,
uh, within the environment, run that simple script
and then kick off, you know, an item over into Dynamo
if that uh or if that file
is present or not.
Now we're not gonna wait for,
uh, all of these, um, but if we just,
you know, run, we can see that we can already have a
few of them that are populating and bringing
in that information.
So again, using automation run
command as a combination you can
perform these actions at scale across your
resources.
Something else that will also help
is called a state manager association.
Think of it as a configuration definition
for these resources, you know,
perform some of those bootstrapping, and we're going
to talk about that in the next section.
So this will go ahead and keep iterating
through. It looks like we're already at 36
steps if we run this one more time,
and we now have 7 nodes that have reported,
you know, whether or not they're compliant.
All right.
So we just talked about,
you know, performing tasks at scale,
you know, through that automation runbook as
well as through run command task.
Now we have a good idea of our our
foundation of node management at this case, you
know, we have an idea of where our resources are
and we have an idea of performing our patch
compliance current state and we
talked about how we can securely connect to
these nodes and then perform actions at scale.
So that brings us into the second section.
Now that we have this good foundation,
we need to be able to monitor those resources,
make sure they're in a healthy state,
you know, gather log information.
Is my application up and running? Are there currently
any issues? And then you could always go back
to that same run command task and
resolve them remotely.
So what are some of the challenges that we hear in a multi-cloud
scenario with regards to observability?
The first is just
very similar to that centralized inventory,
you know, our resources are unmonitored.
They're being spun up, you know, they may not have
the appropriate bootstrapping configurations.
Maybe our application owners are still a little bit
new to thinking about observability.
You know, they may not be building their application with observability
in mind,
so we can have Systems Manager, you know, help
with that process and put in place some initial
configurations for monitoring.
Similar to that, you know, beyond just our metrics,
spans,
traces, and we need to also think about our
logs both for these remote resources
as well as just logs in general that we may be shipping.
They may be scattered across accounts and regions,
and we work with customers that are running on
just a handful of database accounts.
It may be a handful of regions all the way up to hundreds
of database accounts,
multiple different regions.
So how do we bring this into a centralized
location so we can easily query it and get
the information that is needed to help reduce
things like mean time to resolution.
And then finally, how can we actually expose
these operational metrics outside of
the database console,
you know, uh, typically we'll hear from our
customers that they want, you know, to expose
these operational metrics, you know, to their business
leaders or, you know, uh,
higher level reporters that need
to be able to access this data,
but maybe they're not familiar with the database console
or we just don't want them logging in,
you know, uh, considering what else
or what other actions they may perform.
So how can we expose these operational metrics
in an easier way?
So let's uh take a look, oops,
I'll jump over there in a moment.
So talking about uh resources being
unmonitored.
So kind of going back to the assistant manager agent
that we were talking about earlier, if you recall, we
have those temporary credentials that we can use,
uh, so we'll work through an example
here of how we can bootstrap one of these
nodes to have the cloudWatch agent installed
automatically and report metrics and logs
for us. So it still starts as the
exact same, you know, going through that hybrid
activation code process and registering
with systems manager.
And at that point when a node first checks in, it's
going to go ahead and query state manager
for any associations.
Again, associations, think of it as just as
a configuration tool and make a definition
of what scripts or actions you want taken
on that node and put it in place and
then maybe periodically check once a day,
once a week, you know, whatever the appropriate
frequency is.
So here
it's referencing that it's going to go ahead and run
a series of steps to install the cloudWatch
agent using Run command,
and then that that will put in place the cloudWatch
agent. It'll put in place the configuration
for it and then go ahead and start up the
agent as well, so it is then able
to leverage those same temporary
security credentials that the SSM agent is
periodically vending,
and it will be able to report back all of that
information into CloudWatch.
So let's take a look in the console
again. So
that same node, um, let's
close some of these windows.
So that same node that we launched
earlier, that uh Azure
VM4.
If we go back to our explorer nodes and
we pull up
that same resource.
So one of the things that I'll I'll
note here is, you know, this association status. So that's
exactly what I was just talking about,
you know, perform that bootstrapping operation. If
we go down into this association's list,
we can see a few of them that have been
applied against this node.
Now the first one is just going to gather
some inventory data, what applications
are running, what drivers are running on the box.
The second one is performing, you know, that patch
scan. The third one is keeping the SSM
agent up to date.
And then the last one is to go ahead and install
and configure the cloudwatch agent.
So we see that it was successful,
uh, if we.
Then go over,
uh, it's it's.
Let's take a look at that association as
well. So
over here in the state manager section of
the console,
uh,
let's take a look at that install cloud Watch
Association.
Now in here, you know, there's just some basic definitions
we can go ahead and run this once every 7 days.
Again, as soon as a node first checks in with
Systemsandra, it's going to go ahead and query, see that,
hey, I need to apply this.
This is based off of just some tags on
the node. If it's provider and then Azure,
let's go ahead and point to this configuration.
Now what are the the steps that this is actually
performing?
Uh, if we take a look at our underlying
document, it performs, uh, just
3 simple steps.
Uh, so this is going to look a little bit different,
uh, but if I zoom in.
The first step here is just to go ahead
and install the cloudWatch agent.
Uh, the second, you know, this is a simple
shell script, you know, that I've configured to
essentially point the cloudWatch agent to the,
uh, hybrid credentials that the agent or
sorry that the system center agent is vending.
And then down at the bottom just
specifying that we want to use this common
parameter store value
so. When we
are configuring the cloud watch agent.
So if we go over to parameter store.
Let's zoom back out a little bit.
And over here in Parameter store we then have,
you know, the exact configuration that our cloud
watch agent is going to use.
So when you are, you know, building out
what metrics are important for your business
or your applications that are running,
um, you know, you can store this configuration
within parameter store. You can even use, uh, multi-account
sharing, you know, for parameter source. So
from a central location we can make those definitions.
We can then have these nodes, you know, based off
of resource tags,
make the determination of what, uh.
Or sorry, which metrics or which logs in the
OS we actually want to report back
to Cloud Watch.
So if we go over to Cloud Watch now.
And we scroll down, we can go to our metrics
here. And
we'll just, let's see if I can.
Here we go.
So we want Azure VM4,
and now all these are all of those metrics,
you know, that are uh running on the box
now. Um, so the cloudwatch agent
is using those credentials that the
SSM agent vends out. It's able
to uh leverage those to then interact
with AWS, push metrics, push logs,
you know, to this location.
And one last thing that I also want to show is,
you know, beyond just the operating
system, uh, metrics or logs
that we need to collect, you know, there may be other metrics,
uh, over in Azure that I also want to bring in.
So I also want to highlight over in the cloudwaatch settings
section of the console, you can go over to
metric data sources, and you know, this
is where I have a direct connection with Azure
Monitor. So if there are infrastructure related
metrics, you know,
outside of the OS that I also want to be able to query
uh from using CloudWatch, you know, and have this
centralized data set essentially.
Uh, we can go ahead and create some
new data sources.
Now, I'm not going to walk through this process
entirely, but when we go through configuring
the data source for Azure Monitor, you know, we
pass in a few different credentials for our tenant,
our client ID, and then the client's secret.
This, uh, underneath is then going to spin up a cloud
formation template which will put in place a lambda
function so you can query this information,
you know, as needed.
So if we look at the one that is already in place,
if we hit query from CloudWatch now,
uh, we can then select my Azure subscription
where I have this uh configured.
I can select my resource group.
And we can select that same, you know, Azure
VM4
node. Now in this case
I'm going to be taking a look at that same
percent CPU
average in this case,
but Like I was mentioning,
you know, this is where we can then,
uh, monitor any
metric that is being provided by Azure Monitor
and bring it into a central location over in CloudWatch.
All right.
So
So now we got an idea of
having our resources monitored wherever they may
be, you know, as soon as they are spun
up, let's go ahead and get that
information collected into a central location.
Now the second challenge, you know, very similar,
uh, but in this case we're gonna be talking about
our logs are scattered,
you know, they're in our dev environment, they're in our
production environment. When users are responding
to an incident, they have to make sure, am I logging
into the right account at this time.
Now that's an unnecessary burden
and, uh, actually just a few weeks back,
um, what we're gonna be taking a look at is
a way that you can define rules
to bring this information into a centralized account.
So very simple example, let's just say that
we're gonna be building out some rules that we want to say
for our production logs as well as
our development logs.
Let's, let's bring those into our
observability account.
And you can also specify that you want that
same log information to be sent to a
backup region.
Uh, so the awesome thing about this is bringing
it into that first destination region is
available at no additional charges, so you can
have all of this information readily available
for you, that you can then use the various
suite of, you know, cloud watch functionality to
then interact with those logs, whether you need to go
use log insights,
uh, if you want to establish some data protection to,
you know, uh, take a look for any PII
information. Or if you want to then just query
it using, you know, other log analytics tools
like OpenSearch.
So if we
flip into the console again.
So
Uh, let's go back over
to cloud Watch.
So earlier this week, we also
announced the, you know, unified
data storage experience within CloudWatch
and of course, you know, I wanted to just kind of show that
uh along, you know, the same demonstration.
So from this observability account, you
know, from this delegated admin account,
we can get a quick glimpse of where
all of our logs are being ingested by CloudWatch,
you know, across different accounts, OU,
regions, you know, get some initial
metrics around it, any anomalies
that have been detected,
you know, really just kind of see the entire
state of all of our logs as
required. And if we go over
to these data sources section,
um, this is where you can, if I hit enable
here,
you know, this also launched with a variety
of third party data sources that you can also
establish a connection with and establish
these pipelines.
So if we just filter,
you know, for our third party ones, you can
bring in data from these,
you know, various third party sources like CrowdStrike,
Microsoft 365,
you know, Palo Alto, GitHub, Octa, and
so on. So we can have all of this
information flow in through these cloudwatch pipelines.
The other major thing that you can do is that you can perform
transformation on them. So if those logs
need to be
transformed into a well defined structure like
OCSF,
uh, you can have that as part of your pipeline
process. Now the rules
that I wanted to show, this is how we can establish
uh both
uh some telemetry rules, you know, here is
an example where I'm specifying
that cloud trail should be enabled. We're
going to report it back to a
law group here
and then some retention information. So this is a
great way to kind of establish uh
some uh governance around
those accounts, you know, make sure cloud trail is
enabled in those
account regions, make sure, you know, VPC
flow logs are being defined as
configured.
And if we jump
over into our organization settings, we
can then see those rules, you know, to actually centralize
the log information.
So here uh in this example rule I'm
just defining, you know, for the most
part that I just want to gather every single
law group, uh, within my environment.
Now you can of course, you know, provide filters, uh,
so if you only want to capture specific law
groups, you know, down here at the bottom you can
see my example, uh, which is just
saying, you know, if it's a cloud trail
law group, you know, we don't, we don't need to, to centralize
it, uh, but you can also use that
as an example, you know, for your other,
um,
law groups as needed, so.
You know, the, the real important part here is
that when we talk about uh querying,
you know, let's just be, uh,
extreme and say that we just do a select start.
Yeah, we don't need to query all of our law groups. There's
going to be some that are more important for our security
operations or just, you know, day to day
operations that need to be pulled in versus
application owners, you know, they may have a different set of law groups
that they are interested in.
So pulling in all of this information, if we were now
to go back to that log management section.
Uh, if I go to that same
session manager log group,
uh, that is located in my other account,
uh, we can then see, you know, that
same data,
uh, so
hard to tell, but, you know, in that log stream
name, uh, that I have highlighted right now,
that is for that member account, you know, where that
new Ubuntu resource, uh, was registered,
and now I'm in my delegated 9750
account instead.
So I can see all of those same commands that were
just issued in that member account so
I can just go ahead and get that
information as soon as possible when I am
responding to incidents that are occurring.
I don't have to worry about jumping between different
accounts, making sure I have access to those accounts
or those roles,
and we can have all of this information pulled in centrally
and made available for us.
All right,
and.
You know, so we just talked about how we can bring all of
those logs uh across our accounts and
regions,
and the last thing is, you know, now that we have this data
in CloudWatch, what, what do we do with it?
How can we expose this information to our key stakeholders,
so. We will flip
back very quickly into.
Uh, Amazonrifana workspace.
So we're gonna take a look at a Graffana workspace now. This is
the Amazon managedrifana,
but of course, you know, if you are using the open source Grafana,
that is perfectly suitable as well.
Uh, so if we.
Log into Crifana.
Oh, it is asking me to
grab my authenticator, so
let's.
Now, again, the, the reason that you may want to use
Grafana is really just to be able to uh
integrate, you know, with your IDPs, this
example just being Octa.
Uh, so,
the main important part is that you're able to expose
all of this information.
Let me grab my password, very secure.
You know, how can we expose this information without
requiring that the user is able to connect to
the AWS console, you know, go
about our different service pages, you know, kind of
make it as simple as possible for some of those
key stakeholders.
So here we just have a few different example dashboards,
but I'm just gonna pull up one for the
moment. Now this is based off of
our one observability workshop, you know,
there we have a sample pet site
application we can monitor our
metrics and logs about how is our pet site
doing. Are pets getting adopted,
you know, are they, are they experiencing any
issues with that entire
process, you know, as they work through the adoption phase,
and you know we can make all of this information
available to, you know, all of those stakeholders.
So just some simple EKS and ECS
metrics.
If we go over to our connections
here, we can even see that we have, you
know, a few different data sources that are configured right now,
including cloudWatch, X-ray, and then Azure
Monitor.
So if we go to explore our
information now,
yeah, so this is uh still selecting that Azure
monitor metric source.
If we
drill down here,
we're going to select that same,
uh, actually, we're gonna select VM2.
This is the one that I was running those stress tests
on earlier.
So if we then refresh, we can see when
we use Systems Editor to kill that
process, now the node is returning back to its
normal day to day boring
CPU usage of only 0.7%.
All right. So
let's kind of go back and just recap
one more time,
uh, sorry, one more, just a
moment. So talking about, you know, how
we can set up some central centralized observability,
it starts with putting in place, you know, getting
an understanding of our applications,
our metrics, our logs, you know, using Systemsander
as a bootstrapping tool to get.
Uh, the agent in place and ready to report.
Following that, we can use cloudWatch log rule
centralization to bring all of this data
into a single account, uh, so we can easily
access it, and then we can expose those metrics, you
know, using things like Amazon managedrifana,
uh, or even any other dashboards
that are needed.
And Clark is now going to talk about how
Philip 66
was able to achieve some success with this.
Uh, thank you, Eric. That was fantastic. I, I love seeing
those, those demos.
So as we promised, these are real.
Actionable techniques and tools you can start
using today or
when you leave here,
right? And Phillips 66 is
just another example of a customer who's
done this successfully and really
achieved some significant benefits.
So you see that they've increased their visibility
and their productivity by using managed grafana
and Amazon,
Amazon managed
services for Prometheus.
So up to 30% reduction
in their mean time to recover.
So when they do have an impairment, they're able to recover
much more quickly.
That of course has a significant impact to their
business and brings them tremendous value.
And that now they have a single pane of glass
for their observability for all of their services.
Of course we got that single pane of glass, it makes
everything easier. You don't have to start switching
between different views.
You don't get confused about where you're actually looking
at and it allows you to resolve things
quicker, understand what's happening in
a much
faster way.
And with fewer tools,
you have fewer headaches, fewer things to worry
about, fewer things you need to train all
of your DevOps, your SREs, your engineers
on. And this is also gonna give you a
cost optimization.
Fewer tools,
fewer costs.
And of course, if you can observe things centrally
and you can manage them centrally,
including your security.
This is going to increase your security posture.
If you can clearly see what
things are compliant, what are not compliant, where are patches,
where your security policies applied,
ensure that they're done correctly by having it in one central place,
that's gonna give you the ability to have a much greatly
improved
security posture.
And of course you can use both cloud native
and
open source managed services, so we showed
you the managedrifana,
but as Eric mentioned, you can use the open source version
as well, so you have the flexibility
to use whatever tool set meets your
organizational needs.
Eric showed you a couple of tools, but we
of course have other ways that we can help you with this at
AWS.
And believe it or not, this is not the first
year we've done multi-cloud at AWS.
I know you've probably heard a lot
about multi-cloud this year,
but we've been doing multi-cloud at AWS in
one way or another since 2016,
as you can see in this timeline.
Of course
we're continuing to add new capabilities,
new features, new services, new functionality
to help all of you manage your systems as you
grow into multi-cloud
customers.
Um, and so here again we're just highlighting a few
of those, but really again the key is we're
continuing to grow this list, so expect
more and more developments in the multi-cloud
front as we continue to build services
to support you and your business.
So what next? Hopefully you really enjoyed this
talk. Uh, we have some QR
codes here that you can go ahead and scan to get more
information, uh, including information on our hybrid
multi-cloud solutions,
uh, as well as our Amazon.com
blogs site.
Yep, so go ahead and take a, take a moment there. You can see all the
newest posts, you can filter them by category
or tags and search for them, etc.
I see a lot of phones up, so I'm gonna give you a
minute to look at those.
Uh, we also do have, uh, some booths
in the, uh, studio.
So here we can go.
So some very specific blogs we do wanna call out
again though, so, um, one of our searching
through session manager as as Eric showed you today
and as well another one on observability
uh with uh Azure using CloudWatch.
We've got a cloud ops kiosk as well.
Please stop by and see us. I know we're only open until 4 o'clock
today. So, uh, if you get time,
we've got socks and we've got demos
and stickers and fun stuff like that.
And if you have any kind of questions or anything like that,
there's always gonna be somebody there who's more
than happy to help you.
So with that, I would do wanna thank you and please encourage
you to take a moment and fill out your survey
in your application.
We take your feedback.